one of the nice things that we do here
is is the integration across different
parts of the University and in our view
human behavior is part of all of our
energy energy energy future so where do
where do where do people matter well
they matter and whether or not people
will accept energy technologies you can
all think of the controversies having to
do with nuclear power carbon capture and
sequestration hydrofracking is gene
alluded to if people won't buy it that
we won't get it or if we get it it's
only because people will be very unhappy
with it if we provide their their our
technology energy technologies whose
success depends on whether individuals
operate them so we provide fancy in-home
devices to show people how well their
energy works will people understand them
will they understand the signals that
they get will they will they use them if
we offer people direct load control say
so that you can get a better deal on
your electricity if your electric
utility is allowed to cycle it off
during peak demand periods will people
will people accept those deals where we
have as we would not will soon be
possible with with smart grids the
opportunity of time of use pricing so
your electric utility will send you a
signal that tomorrow electricity is
going to be really really expensive if
you don't use it tomorrow you can save
save some money so go to them all and
it's really when it's really hot what
about energy conservation we've all seen
lists of a hundred and fifty things that
you could do to conserve energy do those
make any sense to people are they
feasible in their lives is easy to make
a list it may not be that easily to
execute on it everything that we believe
that we know about energy technology
technologies come we believe that we
know because somebody tells us that so
how well can we trust the experts who
have done the analyses of the risks and
risks and benefits human behavior is the
cornerstone of human behavior of expert
as the cornerstone of probabilistic risk
analysis used to anticipate the
reliability of technologies that we've
never actually seen in operation based
on our understand
of their components and how they fit
together there's uncertainty and all of
these things whether or not we
understand the uncertainty depends on
the comprehensiveness of the team of
experts that we've put together to see
how a technology would work when things
go wrong how well are we able to analyze
and then take action on them and then
all of the energy technologies depend on
on people to keep them going are they
maintaining them the way there's that
they did that they should according to
the according to their plans when things
go wrong does the word get out when
people have innovations are we able as a
society to take to take advantage of
them so there are people everywhere to
get the benefits and the risks of tech
get the largest set of benefits and the
smallest set of risk we need to
understand the human behavior of the
people who operate them the people
consume them the people who approve or
disapprove of public policies and the
people who claim to know how they work
how do we study this what if achill
study will begin with very open-ended
interviews making certain that we
understand the broadest range of views
that people bring to bear on it on a
technology on a technology because all
because we are and one of the most
robust of human we find these in the
behavioral sciences as we exaggerate the
extent to which we can read other
people's minds and they can read read
hours so if you don't talk to people you
don't know what they're what they're
they're thinking about typically will
follow up with structured surveys in
order to find out the prevalence of
beliefs in a particular population
whether it's experts or or lay people
will do lab experiments in order to
refine our understanding of how
particular behavioral processes work and
but then we realize that these are lab
experiments we often don't know how
important the things are that we
discover in the lab are in the real
world you run an experiment whether it's
in psychology or or biology in order to
get the largest possible variability in
the in the phenomena that interests you
but they may be much larger in the lab
lab than they are
in the world as a result you need to do
field experiments in order to see how
fully functioning interventions or
technologies technologies work a field
experiments are all if you are all
complicated up or complicated operations
and you can say well how we've tried to
introduce in home devices or different
kind of payment schemes for electricity
what do we know from them so a naive way
of accumulating those data would be to
say well how often did it work and how
often didn't it didn't it work if you do
that then you end up treating all
studies as equal or some of them are
clearly better than others so you can
use a technique called meta-analysis
developed originally but from clinical
psychological clinical trials now used
in medical to clinical trials to see
what kind of a signal we have about
about the efficacy of different
different programs you can develop
communication programs so that you have
the best chance of getting a fair
judgment of technologies and so that
people understand what they are you can
develop consultation schemes an
interesting example is we recently had a
blue ribbon at the federal level had a
blue ribbon commission on the on on
America's nuclear future that was
particularly prompted by trying to
figure out what to do with with
radioactive waste that comes the
Commission decided to have a road show
of consultations going around the
country to see what people thought about
it a review by social scientists
realized that they had scheduled this in
a way that they had set this up in a way
there was actually likely to antagonize
people rather than to make them feel
more more inclusive included in the
pendant in the process and the final
recommendations of the blue ribbon
ribbon commission was a way it was were
recommendations for using scientifically
sound the soliciting a soliciting public
involvement and finally something that
Granger and his colleagues have been
been pioneers in is how do you
systematically elicit judgment from
experts and then communicated in people
so that they know how good the best
judgement of expert technology of our
advanced technologies are here's a few
of the projects that we've done in the
past colleagues and I 30 years ago wrote
a book for the nuclear regulatory
commission called acceptable risk
basically it's still in its still in
print the the NRC came to us because
there had been a belief that if you made
nuclear power absolutely safe and people
would just accept it and for those who
followed the future of the industry
however strong the assurances in the
engineering for safety that was not not
enough so he said well how what are the
different ways that you can do it
whether the political and social
philosophy you can have a Granger and I
and some others about 20 years ago wrote
a a booklet we sold several hundred
thousand copies of at cost otherwise
we'd be wealthy by now about the health
effects of 60 60 Hertz electromagnetic
fields I tried to level with the public
about what we knew and what we and what
we what we didn't know it it's my
impression that we significantly
affected the national debate on that
there are in smoove done Studies on the
siting of trends of transmission lines
were often you'll find opposition to
transmission line based on health
effects coming from people who are not
that much concerned about health effects
but actually concerned about being
treated shabbily in the sighting process
but being treated shabbily often doesn't
have standing but you can argue about
health effects and you can get had some
attempt to get the kind of redress that
wasn't those otherwise than I do we've
developed methodologies for how to set
priorities among mung risk we've been
studying for 20-odd years how people
understand the understand climate change
what are the barriers to understanding
where the barriers to understanding
often come from the expert community who
explain things so explain things in a in
a poor way we've done work Paul fish pic
and his colleagues have done work on the
safety of tankers and oil and oil
platforms what do we have going on now
we've just about ready to send off a
review a study of the Hawthorne effect
at the electricity field truck so the
Hawthorn effects legendary in the social
sciences toxin which is if you do things
sometimes people be respond just because
they're in a study and we have a lot of
attempts to change people's behavior
relative to electricity mostly they're
mostly in the grey literature of
technical technical reports there often
have effects that are in the Hawthorne
effect range it's helped you raise
people's awareness of electricity and
they'll change their behavior so if you
all you need to do is ray is raise
people's behavior well you don't need in
home devices you don't need a lot of the
other expensive things that we're doing
we've just completed a meta-analysis of
smart grid field trials finding most of
them to be methodologically flawed and
in ways that based on the research
literature you can suggest extent to
which they mostly exaggerated the
effects of their of their trials we've
done work on the perceived risks and
benefits of smart grid with a paper just
coming up terms of people love smart
smart meters except they expect them to
be the equivalent of jet packs that they
they love them because they think
they'll do a whole lot more than a than
they actually do and they and they have
fears that people didn't think about it
we're looking at markets for ancillary
services could you sell people up the
right to poor quality of energy energy
that comes from comes from renewable
source to enable the system to absorb
the unreliability that you that that you
have we've looked at these other these
are the other topics so why do we do
these things here well we have a very
broad set of disciplines we have a long
history of collaboration across colleges
and within colleges we have a tradition
here of applying basic research and it
to see how much of what we believe to be
true actually is true turns out to be
valid in reality and conversely a long
tradition of attending basic identifying
basic research topics not in da janela
from our own research programs from
confrontation with apply the problems
that we all
have large invisible colleagues of
colleges of colleagues and often people
are happier working in traditional
disciplines but we can pull them into
doing this kind of basic and applied
research that this institute is
dedicated to thank you